ein ganz normaler samstag morgen bei
familie geier in berlin
die eltern freuen sich auf ein
gemeinsames frühstück die beiden söhne
und deren cousine beschäftigen sich mit
ihren smartphones
seit sie neun jahre alt sind besitzen
sie eigene geräte
man hat so ein bisschen kontrollverlust
latent schlechtes gewissen wenn man
irgendwas zuletzt habe ich schon guckt
er da was ganz fürchterliches was
überhaupt nicht viel für ihn gedacht ist
für ausgaben mattila und gustav sind
smartphones das wichtigste medium und
messenger dienste wie whatsapp sind die
häufigsten anwendungen 70 prozent der
deutschen kinder kommunizieren so am
liebsten mit ihren freunden 50 prozent
nutzen spiele apps oder soziale
netzwerke wie instagram heck ein
smartphone hat kann nicht mitreden
viele hatten und ich halt beeindruckt
war was man damit alles machen kann wir
haben auch ein klassen chatten damit
halten geschrieben obwohl es auch nervig
ist weil nachts geht's halt durchgehend
und dann muss man halt eure flug wurde
schalten aber das benutze ich am
häufigsten
für den 9 und die zwölfjährigen gilt nur
eine eiserne regel beim essen bleiben
die smartphones außen vor
darüber hinaus gibt es keine festen
vereinbarungen
jeden tag wird neu verhandelt wie lange
sie digitale medien nutzen dürfen
da geht es noch darum dass man
alternativen anbietet und vorlebt dass
man drauf steht irgendwas unternimmt das
heißt sie haben noch andere interessen
und vorstellungen was man so mit seiner
zeit machen kann und wenn sie dann nach
einem langen tag draußen oder nach
fußballtraining oder sowas abends so ein
bisschen konzentrieren mit dem mit dem
handy in ehrenfeld es auch okay
eine häufige sorge der eltern die kinder
würden konzentrationsstörungen bekommen
wenn sie zu lange digitale angebote
nutzen
sarah lange kennt die bedenken sie berät
eltern und lehrer zum thema medienkonsum
von kindern ihre beobachtung smartphones
können auch hilfreich sein
sieht man häufig wenn man projekte mit
kindern und jugendlichen durchführt dass
medien
große ziele
große erfolge verbuchen können wenn zum
beispiel kinder die aufmerksamkeit
schwäche haben sich dann tatsächlich mal
auf etwas konzentrieren in dem projekt
familie geier hat keine jugendschutz
software auf ihrem computer aktiviert
wie dabei spielen noch beim surfen
die kinder sollen eigenständig den
sinnvollen umgang mit internet inhalten
lernen wichtig ist hinterher darüber zu
sprechen und grenzen gemeinsam zu setzen
dazu raten auch experten es ist ganz
wichtig dass in familien ein gutes
verhältnis herrscht wo man mit problemen
mit ängsten mit sorgen aufeinander
zugehen kann und dafür ist es ganz
wichtig kinder und jugendliche zu
verstehen und sie auch in ihrer
mediennutzung zu verstehen dass wir sie
ihren eltern nicht leicht für kinder und
jugendliche verschwimmen offline und
online welten
beim spiel koppmann golf beispielen
chats und apps sind sie ihren eltern oft
voraus allerdings manche anwendungen
nutzen inzwischen die gesamte familie
wie selbstverständlich so ist es heute
viel einfacher ein kontakt zu bleiben
dank der smartphones es ist halt die
kulturtechnik wenn man da nicht bescheid
weiß und damit umgehen kann unter flink
ist weil die eltern bildungsbürgerlicher
weise einen die ganze zeit nur gezwungen
haben bücher zu lesen dann kann es auch
schwierig werden wenn man später meinen
job finden will und deswegen finde ich
verhindern irgendwie blödsinn aber man
muss es so ein bisschen bewusst
begleiten und gucken dass es nicht aus
dem ruder läuft
digitale medien haben die familien
erobert